FIRST, MY OPENING STATEMENT.
>> THEY'VE STOLEN THE HOUSE.
THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE.
FOUR FOUNDERS CREATED TO
REPRESENT THE PEOPLE AS WELL AS
THE CLOSEST TO THE PEOPLE.
THEY HIJACKED IT TO MAINTAIN
POWER FOR THEMSELVES.
THEY DON'T WORK FOR OR REPRESENT
YOU.
THEY OBSTRUCT THE WORK THEY WERE
SENT TO DO BY HUGH SO THEY CAN
SCORE THEIR OWN POLITICAL POINTS
AND GET THE REVENGE THEY SO
DESPERATELY SEEK.
THEY HATE OUR COMMANDER IN
CHIEF.
THESE RADICALS WHO HAVE
FORFEITED THEIR JOB REPRESENTING
YOU, CONTINUES TO RESIST, CREATE
HAVOC AND CLAIM CONSTANT PRICES.
>> WE TALKED FOR A LONG TIME
ABOUT APPROACHING A
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS, WE ARE
NOT IN IT.
WE ARE NOT IN A CONSTITUTIONAL
CRISIS WITH THE CONSTITUTIONAL
CRISIS.
>> WE ARE.
EVERYONE A CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS
LOOKS LIKE?
OPEN YOUR I.
>> WE HAVE NOT ENTERED THAT
CRISIS.
>> I'M CURIOUS BECAUSE ISN'T
THAT THE HEIGHT OF A CRISIS?
>> TRUMP HEADING TOWARD A
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS WITH
DEMOCRATS AS HE CONTINUES TO
HIDE THE MUELLER REPORT.
>> THIS ADMINISTRATION WANTS TO
HAVE A CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS.
>> CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS?
HOW?
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T GET THE FULL
MUELLER REPORT?
THEY ALL STUPID?
THEY HAVE 98% OF THE FULL
REPORT.
I GOT NEWS FOR YOU BOZOS, YOU
WEREN'T EVEN ENTITLED TO ANY OF
IT.
THE REPORT WAS WRITTEN FOR THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL BY THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL DECIDED TO
ISSUE A FOUR-PAGE CONCLUSION AND
OFFER DEMOCRATS THE FACILITY TO
SEE THE WHOLE REPORT.
NOT ONE DEMOCRAT WANTED TO SEE
IT.
SO ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR WAS IN
THE IMPOSSIBLE POSITION OF
VIOLATING FEDERAL LAW AND
RELEASING JURY TESTIMONY OR THE
DEMANDS OF THE RADICAL LEFT.
THE ONLY CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS
IS THE ONE CREATED BY OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS OF A
FALSE RUSSIA COLLUSION, SPUN BY
THAT MASTER HIMSELF, JIM COMING.
THE DISGRACED FORMER HEAD OF THE
FBI.
WE FIND OUT THIS WEEK, THE FBI
WAS ON FULL NOTICED TO STEAL IT
WAS FAKE EVEN BEFORE THE PRODUCT
TO THE JUDGE.
AND USE IT AS A SOLE BASIS TO
SPY ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THAT'S DARKNESS HIMSELF, COMING
NEW ALL ALONG THE DOSSIER WAS A
FRAUD.
EVEN ADMITTING TO THE PRESIDENT
IN JANUARY 2017, IT WAS
UNVERIFIED.
YET, THIS SUBVERSIVE, USED IT TO
SPY ON THE MAN HE AND HIS BY
FELT, DIDN'T DESERVE TO OCCUPY
THE OVAL OFFICE.
ONLY HAS A CLINTON CLAN SAYING
THIS WEEK, WE DON'T SPY, WE
INVESTIGATE.
JIM, HER WHO ARE YOU KIDDING?
DID DOSSIER WAS BS THING AND NO.
THE FBI KNEW IT WAS A POLITICAL
DOCUMENT AND GET IT DONE BEFORE
THE ELECTION.
CERTAINLY NOT AN INTELLIGENCE
DOCUMENT.
THE ASSIGNED THREE WANT
APPLICATIONS BASED ON THIS FAKE
DOSSIER.
YOU, THE FBI, D.O.J. COMMITTED A
FRAUD ON THE COURT.
MASSIVE ABUSE OF POWER.
A CLEAR VIOLATION OF OUR LAWS.
YET, YOU COME OUT OF THE SHADOWS
THURSDAY NIGHT BECAUSE YOU KNOW
THE JIG IS UP.
>> YES, I THINK SPINE DID OCCUR.
I BELIEVE THERE IS A BASIS FOR
MY CONCERN.
I THINK SPYING ON A POLITICAL
CAMPAIGN IS A BIG DEAL.
>> THE APPLICATION IS PRESENTED
AS VERIFIED, A POLITICAL
DOCUMENT TO PROTECT YOUR
GIRLFRIEND, HILLARY WHO YOU,
YOUR INSUBORDINATE SELF LOOSE
SAYING SHE HAD NO INTENT TO BUY
THE THE LAW AND YOU HAVE THE
NERVE TO SAY TRUMP OBSTRUCTED
JUSTICE?
IT SURE LOOKS LIKE IT.
JIM, YOU WOULDN'T KNOW
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE IF IT'S
LEFT YOU IN THE FACE.
YOUR GUILFORD, HILLARY,
OBSTRUCTED EVIDENCE BY LINE,
DELETING 30,000 EUROS, WE
WOULDN'T KNOW THE TRUTH.
YET, THE TREATMENT OF DONALD
TRUMP IS STUNNING.
IN A FAKE RUSSIA COLLUSION
CLAIM, THERE WERE 3600 SUBPOENA
SUBPOENAS, 500 SEARCH ONCE,
INVESTIGATIONS OF 30 COUNTRIES,
500 WITNESSES QUESTIONED, 18
LAWYERS, 40 INVESTIGATORS,
CRIMINAL GRAND JURIES IN PANEL,
THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF HANDED
OVER 1.4 BILLION DOCUMENTS AND
NEVER CLAIMED EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE.
HE WAS HARASSED.
FRIEND, PERSECUTED, TORMENTED,
INSULTED AND PROVOKED.
HIS FAMILY THE SAME.
AND YOU CALL ME, DARE TO SHOW
YOUR FACE IN PUBLIC?
SO BILL BARR HELD IN CONTEMPT BY
THE SAME CONGRESS THAT SAYS TO
HELP WITH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND THEIR WORK, WE WANT MONEY
OFF BARR SO WHEN HE STARTS
INDICTING US, WE CAN SAY IT'S
ALL POLITICAL.
IT'S NO WONDER THAT ALMOST 80%
OF AMERICANS DO NOT APPROVE OF
THE WAR CONGRESS IS DOING.
I PERSONALLY THINK IF THEY DON'T
DO THE WORK WE SENT THEM
THEREFORE, THEY SHOULDN'T GET A
SALARY.
IT SHOULDN'T GET A PENSION.
NOR SHOULD THEY BE ALLOWED TO GO
ON JUSTICE OR GET FREE
HEALTHCARE.
IF YOU DON'T APPROVE OF THE
GAMESMANSHIP GOING ON IN THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES, FIND
OUT HOW YOUR REPRESENTATIVE IS.
SEND A LETTER OR AN E-MAIL OR
JUST PICK UP THE PHONE.
I DOUBT THEY'LL CARE.
THE ONLY PAPER THEY RESPOND TO
IS THIS.
DON'T LIMIT YOURSELF TO THOSE IN
YOUR DISTRICT.
WE ARE ONE COUNTRY, ONE AMERICA.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE WHAT THEY ARE
DOING, FIND OUT WHO'S RUNNING
AGAINST THEM.
WHETHER IT'S A PRIMARY OR
GENERAL ELECTION.
GET INVOLVED.
LET YOUR VOICE BE HEARD.
MOST IMPORTANT, START GEARING UP
FOR 2020.
WE NEED A HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES THAT REPRESENTS
THE PEOPLE IN THIS GREAT NATION.
THE PEOPLE WHO WANT TO REMAKE
AMERICA AND MAINTAIN THEIR OWN
POWER.
GOD HELP US AND GOD HELP US IF
WE ELECT THESE SAME PEOPLE AND